lyft is facing a new sexual assault  lawsuit Alyson Turco says her driver  kidnapped her at gunpoint in New York  City in 2017 drove her across state  lines and then raped her with two other  men Turco's is among a reported five  women who filed lawsuits against lyft  yesterday alleging they were sexually  assaulted or raped by lyft drivers the  plaintiffs accused lyft of refusing to  cooperate with law enforcement in rape  cases failing to adequately screen  potential drivers and failing to address  what they call the sexual predator  crisis on the platform for its part lyft  just last week issued updates concerning  its safety features and said it will  make drivers undergo a mandatory safety  exercise as for turkos claim the company  says what the writer describes is awful  in this case the driver passed in New  York City TLC's background check and was  permitted to drive lyft says it's  permanently deactivated that driver in  question but would not say when they did  that